hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John and the the channel is
still not he's still not here on
December 10th but we're here here
figuring out how to get the channel back
has been like running through a maze
one might say there have been many
trials yes along the way and maybe
there's a cure for this feeling of death
The Maze Runner the death cure final
trailer I barely remember the Scorch
Trials I barely remember that movie I
remember thinking it was okay all I
remember is it set it ends with a setup
for the third one good to be young no
serious you haven't seen it I know you
haven't seen the Scorch Trials well
let's check it out right now let's check
out the third one I hear they've really
revamped the style and today's patient
the day shad are gonna go for Natalie
Doran Natalie Doran
[Music]
so Mad Max yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh this looks dope
I can handle Thomas show up eventually
that's what I'm afraid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wicked and like that you can save your
friends or you can save us all
[Music]
my god first we gonna destroy some [ __ ]
[Music]
well it's end of January so might be a
good movie basically a February what I
gotta say about this trailer in terms of
directing and cinematography I feel like
they actually have a specific visual
style whereas I felt like the second one
didn't really have that the first one
yeah I would say so they've really taken
a different approach to this I mean I
was really pulled into the action
sequences that we were seeing here it's
like yeah first thing comes my fury road
us yeah it's gonna be a thing that
people reference now whenever you see
deserted yeah all the action sequences
look amazing in this trailer it really
looks like they threw down for stunts
and crashes they're going out for a big
finale here when it looks like what's
the dude's name again I want to call him
Logan Lerman
Dylan O'Brien Dylan O'Brien looks like
he's like Tom Cruise in it on this you
can usually tell a certain amount of
like oh this was shot on a screen or
whatever but like cement stuff on like
the hood of the car yeah it looks like
him well for American assassinated a lot
of his own stunts - yeah yeah and I feel
like jumping off of that I don't know
where they were made in relation to each
other but he seems like he's really
taking this all very seriously and that
makes this look more compelling than you
know the previous thing just forget all
the intricate details forgot what wicked
was the wck D yeah I was like oh yeah
it's the company that put this together
the lady who he's holding the gun up at
the end she's want to created it she's
the leader of it why would she call it
wicked
that sounds sup w ck d yeah anybody with
a market testing department knows the
you should probably
I don't know any wicked man because it's
cool so we know who the villain is
reading it in terms of like wanting to
finish this story I'm not really like I
got a tune in for that because I don't
ever remember the story of this thing
well not making me like it's to go back
gotta want to see more actions and I go
I'll figure it out one
like I'm sure they'll remind me of
anything I needed to know which sounds
opposite towards a lot of what you and I
tend to say about movies yeah you know
the story is totally important but I'm
not really drawn to this story
I've seen this trailer I really just
want to see more cool action set-pieces
because whatever they change locations
to action moments I'm like this looks
cool I'm getting angry and yelling at
each other you know having the basic
human nature emotional stuff oh yeah
yeah all that is what I'm drawn to but I
don't even remember the story well
enough to be like I got to finish this
this trilogy yeah your story's always
important and in this context I just
sort of accept that this this movie
isn't made with me in mind yeah I
haven't read the books I'm not you know
itching to read the books so I come at
this from an angle of like this looks
pretty cool this isn't for me enough
that I'm gonna stress over the story and
I like doing well Brian a lot I think
the UM Ryan's a really damn good actor
so any time you please Thomas and the
regime's Thomas hatred a shout out is
gonna go out to Natalie Doran Natalie
Doran natalie is one of our top patrons
and she's this beautiful Irish gal she
was the first one to tell me about this
Maze Runner trailer dropping so I was
like BAM you bookmark your shoutout
right through there and I know she
really likes Dylan O'Brien
so Natalie here's I'm gonna tell you if
you fly to America and you stalk Dylan
O'Brien I'm pretty sure he put out for
you it's not sexual harassment I'm not
talking about me I'm talking about Dylan
O'Brien a man you're very attracted to
you would love to do drill and O'Brien
drillin O'Brien O'Brien is one of the
better yeah yeah hey I mean and then
you're gonna receive a Dylan orgasm
you're more beautiful than half the
actresses he's been seen with so I'm
telling you you have a shot love you
Natalie you're the bomb and you're super
pretty and you're super sweet and you're
super funny and say hi to calories for
us subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell you could
download and follow us on the Stardust
app first people posting regularly over
there and become a patron oject today oh
yeah
question for the audience who do you
prefer logan lerman or dylan o'brien
or do you think they're the exact same
person comment below